Hello! VidCon is a weird time of the year
to make a video.
[Grunting] I'm overwhelmed so i'm recording this
a little bit early meaning I'm recording
it on tuesday.
John, your video just came out, and so
here I am and I'm going to do a Question
Tuesday because I'm making a video on
Tuesday which never happens also because
doing anything more complicated than a
question Tuesday would destroy me.
But I'm fine.
I'm good. So let's go on to Twitter: Hey,
it's question Tuesday, the day that I
answer real questions from real nerdfighters!
I got partway through and then
I gave up. Opinions on gerrymandering?
That's not really a question, though you
didn't put a question mark at the end of
it. I think you should watch CGP Grey
video about it.
Sports with John asks, Why aren't you
watching the USMNT? Don't know what that
is. Danny makes a great point that the
USMNT is almost certainly the United
States mutant ninja turtles. Easy might
be adopting two kittens tomorrow, what should she name them?
Asiago and Cheddar.
Patrick wants to know if I have any
tricks for conquering insomnia.
I react to stress with sleep
I'm like a, like one of those sheep that
gets scared and falls over. Or are those
goats? Most of the times i have
suffered from insomnia, it has been
because I drank caffeine so I just don't
do that. I know that seems very extreme
to a lot of people but I don't have that much of a
problem with it. Favorite kind of M&M?
Peanut.
If you could have a fictional person be
a guest at VidCon who would it be?
I like this question. Luna Lovegood,
Galadriel, Huck Finn? That's hard, that's a
hard one. I'm gonna I'm gonna have to
write a fanfic. Describe your feelings
about VidCon being this week. I don't get
to think a lot about it. It just happens.
I form very few memories because they go
straight from one thing to the other and
I never have time to think about
anything. But this one's going to be
particularly intense I think because we
are launching, announcing three things
We are launching membership for the
Internet Creators Guild. You can go and
become a member of the Guild if you are
a creator on the internet. The ICG is
basically just a thing that promotes the
interests of Internet creators. We're
also announcing that there will be two
new VidCons, which is huge and kind of
shocking that it's finally happening.
We're doing a VidCon in Melbourne
Australia and a VidCon in Amsterdam and
also, I forgot about this because I can't
tell you about it, we're announcing
another thing on Saturday, which is
tomorrow when this video comes out and I can't tell you about it yet. I'm sorry
about that, but we're going to announce
it during the nerdfighter meet up
so you have to be there, or be somewhere
else slightly afterward because i'm sure
people will be tweeting about it.
It's the kind of thing that you might
want to pay attention to if you live
near or in Boston.
That's all I'm going to say. On a scale of one to ten
what's your favorite
color of the alphabet? Going to have
to say trurpee. How do you feel about
avocados?
That's an easy one, also the multiverse is
the the addition to that query, the two
parter.
Okay, well I love avocados, I also love
the multiverse.
If the multiverse theory is true there's
there is a universe in which I am an
avocado. What color are your socks?
It's a good color and also these these
colors as well and that's how we're
going to end it.
Thank you so much to everybody who took
my homework assignment and did it. There
were so many letters that I got on
snapchat and Facebook and Tumblr and
Twitter. Things like this remind me that
we are still doing things with people and
not just at people and also it reminds
me that we are a part of how the world
creates itself and I'm very thankful to
all the people who took the time to
write to someone in their government
about something they were passionate
about. John, I would say that I would see
you on Tuesday but I'm going to see you
before then. So I will see you very
shortly.
Good video by the way this week.